say again is loki really dead i heard
that
oh he went to the back of the ship i see
listen
i've heard some amazing theories about
this um
i was in a park in london a couple of
weeks ago
and uh some guys like
come and say hi and they asked me the
same question and they said listen they
said hey listen
i don't know we need an answer to this
question
all the other times loki's died there
have been a few
um he
he stabs with his right hand and now
he's stabbing with his left hand
i was like that's incredible attention
to detail were you aware of that detail
was that were you aware of that detail
no
unintentional um
oh dear um there's a lady loki there's a
kid loki
there's uh he's he's pansexual in some
in some extraordinary way
yeah um so will you
be doing
any of the other hokies
no don't if you're iraq what are you
asking exactly
are you going to do a loki that's
not archetypal male 1 i think
if anyone wants to tell that story i'm
not the guy
okay okay i think i think that needs to
be a woman or
someone who identifies as a woman yeah
well we're at the same place as you are
which is having seen infinity war
and and these six infinity stones and
actually the the mind stone is the thing
that connects these two
and also a sense of i think sacrifice
because i think the thing you have to do
at the end of infinity war is a kind of
sacrifice
yeah i would agree um and arguably loki
makes a similar one
um yeah here's what i wanted to know
the nightmare that tony stark has
gone back yeah yeah so you you go around
and you give everyone a nightmare
his nightmares it's the it's
yes so i wondered is that connected to
what happens in infinity war
is that did tony see it coming in his
mind and you connected
him to that i i don't know
i don't know if that's what could have
happened
if ultron took over i see i'm not sure
yeah i think it's up to interpretation
because i don't
it wasn't something that i remember
someone was saying that we're going to
go full circle
infinity war yeah there wasn't an
infinity war at that time
um but i think i always thought of it as
it being what would happen
if ultron won yeah
but i think it's more interesting the
way you're thinking about it
well maybe tony's got the long view yeah
yeah
cool good talk high five i think it's
also isn't it understanding the process
behind making these films and as
i think everybody at marvel i think they
have they take
huge confidence with every new leap um
kevin feige has told me that the fact
that people enjoyed the first thor film
gave him the confidence to dream
guardians of the galaxy into existence
he thought
okay people accept that superheroes are
going to leave earth and go into space
and and then when guardians worked it
was like he knew
he could start cooking infinity war and
i think so
as marvel have grown in in their
extraordinary
and unprecedented creative confidence i
think i felt more confident in their
processes
hey everybody it's charlie we got new
loki and scarlet witch avengers 4
stuff to break down just like chris
evans did that comic-con panel last
weekend
they did one too talking about all kinds
of stuff we also got some details about
when marvel is actually planning on
dropping that avengers 4 trailer so i'll
talk about that after i talk about
loki's stuff that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway is still going on there's
actually new dlc
dropping for that soon all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a marvel related comment on the
video
they talked about a whole bunch of
really cool stuff i tried to cut this
video down to the most
important parts about stuff that's
coming up in the future because
both of them in addition to what's
happening with avengers 4 marvel phase 4
both of them have tv series based on
their characters coming to that disney
streaming service
the biggest thing being tom hiddleston
directly addressing what happened to
loki on that ship
and he went on for a great deal of time
talking about loki's sacrifice
and how he was redeemed in that moment
so when he starts talking about all the
other versions of loki and going on
about the character's history and how
complicated it gets and how marvel can
explore that story in the future
i think that's him implying that loki
really did die
in that moment permadeath his sacrifice
wouldn't mean as much if they took it
right back during avengers 4.
the loki that we've been talking about
during avengers 4 is just an
earlier version of the character from
the actual battle of new york so he's a
little bit younger he's dressed in the
costume for that period but that doesn't
mean that they don't also
reference the version of loki that died
and his spirit lives on
in the afterlife depending on whether or
not you think that he is able to enter
valhalla but because of the way marvel
plays it a little bit fast and loose
with norse mythology
i think that odin is powerful enough to
help loki enter
valhalla so just because he might be
dead doesn't mean that he's not still
able to play tricks
from beyond the grave because if odin
can speak with thor
from valhalla then loki could probably
do it too the other really funny
encounter that he describes people
coming up to him in the park asking me
about little plot details
is this a clue that loki might still be
alive the deal with the right-handed
dagger versus using his left hand in
infinity war
tom hiddleston was really surprised by
that had no
idea that loki typically favored his
left hand when using his dagger in
all of his previous appearances but
during infinity war he mysteriously uses
his right hand
so i think that's just a minor
continuity error and not something that
they were thinking about on the day like
oh wow i didn't you know i didn't know
what was going on with that
just another reason why i think that
they truly intended for him to die in
that moment regardless of what marvel
does with the character in the future
he also kind of confirms that marvel
might be thinking about doing future
other versions of loki and other media
not necessarily in the movies but
somewhere out there you might see a kid
version of loki or the female version of
loki
and he confirms that it would have to be
different actors playing that character
but just to be clear the loki tv series
that they're doing on that disney
streaming service
will be tom hiddleston and he'll be
playing his version of the character
presumably from a different part of the
timeline they haven't told us
too much about what's going on with that
other than it'll probably be like 8 to
10 to maybe 13 episodes tops
they haven't told us too much about the
actual plot or structure of that other
than it'll probably be
mini series size like eight to ten
episodes tops
usually people like tom hiddleston
mainly film actors
don't do really really long tv runs
that's probably how they're able to do
these big movie characters on tvs by
telling them will only make you do like
8 to 10 episodes so just be prepared for
them to not do
five seasons of loki it might just be
one season of loki then they move on to
scarlet witch's season
then they do another season with another
movie character during a different part
of the timeline
we'll follow up on that when we learn a
little bit more about it for those of
you asking about the new avengers 4
trailer rumor now the rumor is is that
it's going to be dropping
sometime during november maybe early
december on good morning america which
jives what they did with the infinity
war trailer they dropped you know the
first big footage towards the end of
november so right now
people are saying november 21st the 28th
or december 12th which seems weird that
they would jump all the way to december
12th
i think it's more likely that it would
be the week of november 21st if we get
any more information about that i'll
totally do a video about it
but there's also been another trailer
that's supposedly posted to reddit that
seems much more
legit so if you want me to do a video
about that just let me know in the
comments because there's going to be a
whole bunch of avengers 4 stuff
happening regardless towards the end of
the year there's some new spider-man far
from home footage to break down and a
new look at mysterio's
tech costume so i'll probably do those
videos in the next couple of days i'll
name the giveaway winner when i post new
marvel there'll be new flash episode
posting later tonight too
click here for my breakdown of that
avengers 4 trailer and click here to
watch chris evans talk all about
avengers 4.
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you